bonjour bonjour merci de nous recevoir
chez vous ça me fait plaisir vous allez
bien très très bien vous êtes en forme
en format santé émerger c'est la santé
il y a rien et quand on a la santé c'est
tellement une grande privilège c'est un
privilège aussi grand que celui d'être à
80 ans puis d'être encore là le matin
pour voir le soleil et puis vous parlez
des années qui par 50 ans en 2022 la
marque lise watti a eu 50 ans est-ce que
c'est objet de fierté que ça existe
toujours 50 ans plus tard
messieurs messieurs parce que quand on
commence une compagnie comme je l'ai
fait on vit au jour le jour c'est à dire
que j'anticipe d'aller plus loin d'aller
toujours plus loin d'aller à
l'international et c'est sûr que j'avais
des ambitions qui m'amenaient à
poursuivre c'était mon moteur alors oui
je suis fière de voir que cette
compagnie québécoise là vit
harmonieusement avec 50 ans d'existence
dire de Lise Watier qu'elle est
ambitieuse est un euphémisme elle a
toujours vu grand
né au début des années 40 dans le
quartier oslaga Maisonneuve à Montréal
la jeune lise Wattier apprend rapidement
à saisir les occasions qui se présentent
la télévision par exemple
pour le réveillon du jour de l'an une
suggestion du chef de La Saulaie
chroniqueuse et animatrice elle se fait
rapidement connaître dans les années 60
elle devient une référence crédible une
reine de beauté aux yeux des
téléspectatrices qui lui écrit pour des
conseils vous descendez
par cette renommée elle fonde en 1968
l'Institut charme et beauté une école où
l'on offre des cours de maquillage et
d'estime de soi son succès est
instantanéens
sa propre gamme de cosmétiques
crème fard à paupières rouge à lèvres
les années 80 marque une croissance
débridée pour la jeune entreprise on
exporte aux États-Unis en France et le
parfum neige atteint même le sommet des
fragrances les plus vendues au Canada à
la fin des années 90
lise Wattier cosmétiques enregissent un
chiffre d'affaires de 27 millions en
2007 elle vend tout d'abord à des
intérêts ontariens puis en 2016
Wattier revient au Québec avalé par le
groupe Marcel
tout le monde sait que les cosmétiques
sont industrie très importante sur la
planète mais je ne savais pas à quel
point avant de repérer votre entrevue
560 milliards en 2021 ils disent que ça
va arriver à 700 milliards en 2025 les
médicaments dans le monde c'est 1000
milliards
donc le cosmétique est-ce que comment ça
se fait qu'une entreprise du Québec a
réussi à rester dans ce marché-là très
compétitif c'est des gros groupes est-ce
que vos produits étaient aussi bons que
leur produit mes produits étaient
souvent meilleurs que leurs produits à
un prix inférieur une qualité de
produits ne se juge pas nécessairement à
son prix je vais vous donner un exemple
prenons les grandes compagnies que ce
que soit américaine ou française
elles annoncent dans les magazines à
travers le monde on s'entend bien qu'une
page de magazine ça tourne autour de 50
000 dollars iOS qui paient pour ses
publicités
la consommatrice donc les produits lise
wattiers aujourd'hui vous dites n'ont
rien à envier encore à L'Oréal à
l'encontre absolument enfin tout seul
absolument pas les emballages peuvent
différer c'est sûr et puis il y a des
femmes pour qui le statut de dire ah
j'ai un produit de telle marque ça me
valorise c'est bien mais d'autres vont
dire moi j'ai un produit québécois et ça
me valorise aussi et je vois une
prolifération chez les Québécoises de
petites compagnies de produits de beauté
alors je me dis j'y suis pour quelque
chose c'est sûr parce que je revois
toutes ces jeunes qui ont tout ça de
petites compagnies intéressantes mais
elles ont l'ambition elles ont la foi
pour créer et dire moi aussi je vais y
aller c'est une porte que j'ai ouverte à
toutes les femmes du Québec et c'est si
vous me demandez si je suis fier de ça
je suis fière de ça oui parce que si
j'ai pu le faire d'autres peuvent aussi
qu'est-ce qu'il y a encore quelle part
de vous il y a encore dans ces produits
là les outils votre âme mon âme
mon souci de qualité
je n'ai jamais fait de compromis
avec des fournisseurs qui voulaient me
proposer un produit de moins de qualité
et je n'ai jamais accepté je n'ai jamais
fait de compromis mon âme est là parce
que je pense que j'ai inculqué l'équipe
c'est important de donner la qualité
parce que sans qualité m'accompagner
aurait duré un an ou deux et à cause de
la qualité par exemple on a un nouveau
rouge à lèvres qui est le plus vendu au
pays quand je dis non rouge à lèvres je
parle comme si c'était encore à moi oui
mais c'est une fierté pour moi parce que
c'est si on dit dans le marché prestige
on a le rouge à lèvres le plus vendu au
pays c'est quand même quelque chose
est-ce que vous craignez des fois que
les jeunes générations connaissent moins
les produits les outils parce que les
jeunes beaucoup c'est sur les réseaux
sociaux maintenant vous croyez que on
doit entrer dans ce marché là il faut il
faut entrer dans ce marché là parce que
c'est le marché qui gouverne à peu près
tout en ce moment et une compagnie qui
oublie les jeunes
de se faire à acquérir parce que les
jeunes sont ceux qui c'est la génération
qui s'en vient il y a des compagnies qui
s'occupaient seulement des personnes
âgées puis qui s'en vont à la dérive
parce que c'est le danger qui peut
guetter une marque comme maintenant
c'est pas lisse voiture
de il ne faut pas qu'il tourne le dos
aux jeunes non je pense que aussi le
changement de Lise Wattier à Wattier
c'était pour dissocier un peu la
personne qui est jeune la pensent que
les jeunes mais pas si
elle pense que les gens mais c'est un
peu comme toutes les autres marques où
ils ont laissé tomber le prénom pour ne
garder que le nom et je pense que c'est
un tournant aussi pour aller chercher
une génération plus jeune pas de rouge à
lèvres je me sens
son image de femme parfaite mais
n'est-ce pas aussi une forme d'esclavage
un danger pour des jeunes femmes aux
prises avec des images irréelles et
fabriquées j'ai même pas réfléchi et je
me suis même pas posé la question
comment je vais appeler mon produit
c'était le produit lisoitier tel que je
le pensais tel que je le vivais et je
réalise avec les années que non
seulement le produit qui porte mon nom
mais le peu que j'ai fait ici devient
très lourd parce que je ne peux pas me
permettre un écart je ne peux pas me
permettre une défaillance
ce désir de perfection que vous avez ça
doit être dur à porter parfois vous êtes
extrêmement bien mise toujours vous avez
été toute votre vie professionnelle
comme parfait que c'est dur à lourd à
porter ça me stimule moi le matin je
prends ma douche me maquille je
m'habille c'est stimulant pour moi alors
j'aime pour moi-même même si je vois
personne je parle devant un miroir alors
moi je me reconnais si je suis pas
maquillée pas quoi faire je trouve ça
détriment un peu alors moi dès que je me
lève le matin pour moi pour mon mari
aussi mais mon mari me trouve belle
n'importe comment lui c'est
le droit il est gentil on peut être beau
naturel mais c'est pas un fardeau pour
moi puis c'est pas une obligation je me
sens bien bon vous parlez du fardeau
d'obligation qu'en est-il des femmes qui
sentent que c'est un fardeau et une
obligation cette pression d'être parfait
très maquillée vous n'êtes pas pour ça
non plus non il y a des gens qui sont
très très bien dans leur peau sans aucun
maquillage elles sont bien elles sont
heureuses et c'est une question
d'individu ça dépend peut-être de la
façon dont on a vécu notre jeunesse
chez les jeunes je sais que les
influences maintenant ce sont les
chanteuses et alors on voit déjà par la
façon que les jeunes s'habillent ce que
je veux dire c'est que aujourd'hui on va
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes qui
s'inspirent de la mode des chanteurs qui
emportent le moins possible et ça
devient comme une obsession pour les
jeunes d'avoir ce look d'être mince on
voit beaucoup d'anorexie on voit
beaucoup de problèmes
cette pression de la perfection ce nom
ça c'est une pression de la perfection
mais en plus l'anorexie c'est aussi un
problème mental le système problème qui
est très sérieux mais le confort avec
soi-même ça vient pas des traits ça
vient dans dedans d'un confort avec toi
soit bien dans ta peau soit vrai soit
authentique
moi j'ai appelé l'authenticité à la
télévision parce que quand je faisais
mes émissions au tout début d'ailleurs
on envoie des extraits parfois ça me
fait sourire ou Radio-Canada il fallait
parler à la française et puis il fallait
moi ce français international et je me
vois tellement mal dans ma peau et j'ai
appris à la télé que il faut être vrai
parce que ça ne passe pas c'était pas
vrai
tu te trompes ce
tu fais une gaffe tu trouves ça drôle
puis tu continues mais j'ai appris à
être authentique parce que j'étais très
timide et pour cacher cette timidité tu
recherches une perfection puis vivre
l'imperfection l'imperfection c'est ce
qui nous rend unique parce que la
perfection c'est inconfortable les gens
autour de toi quand tu es parfaite
inconfortable puis moi j'aime cette
confortable avec tout le monde j'aime
tromper j'aime ça rire quand c'est pas
le temps puis je plage souvent alors
j'ai pas de perfection parce que quand
de recherche la perfection on est
vraiment mal dans sa peau mais je l'ai
appris à mes dépenses je l'ai appris
mais c'est intéressant parce que
justement vous avez essayé d'entrer dans
ce modèle là parfait puis quand je
disais tout à l'heure on a l'impression
que vous êtes toujours parfait vous
dites NON je veux pas être parfait je
vais être sincère oui c'est ça moi je
suis pas parfait au contraire madame au
mari
[Rires]
ma prochaine invité bien elle a été
nommée la Montréalaise de l'avenir dans
le domaine des affaires et c'est madame
Lise Wattier que j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir aujourd'hui bonne journée
pionnière en affaires lise Wattier ne
l'a pas eu facile les banquiers étaient
réticents elle a dû se battre faire son
chemin la première femme d'affaires au
Québec a même reçu le prix de l'homme
d'affaires du mois la catégorie féminine
n'existait pas encore en 1983 vous avez
défriché vous êtes peut-être là la
première femme d'affaires entre la plus
connue c'est clair au Québec qui a
fonctionné qui a créé une entreprise
importante tellement qu'il faut je
disais ça des jeunes en réunion une
croyaient pas en 1983 vous avez été
désigné homme de l'année
du mois parce que le magazine il n'y
avait pas de catégorie Femme du mois
économique
j'ai été l'homme mois alors c'est quand
même tout un compliment ou un asse et
j'ai mon certificat d'homme du mois
aussi mais par la suite j'ai réussi à
faire changer le titre par personnalité
du mois
qui était plus je pense que c'est plus
simple et plus mais j'ai été l'homme du
mois en effet pas seulement
les cosmétiques encore aujourd'hui c'est
des gros groupes financiers ce sont des
hommes vous étiez vous détenez là-dedans
là mais c'est votre moteur les oitiers
dans la vie c'est quand vous dit non ne
pas prendre un nom et de je déteste
quand on me dit non je n'aime quand je
dis je déteste
je n'aime pas recevoir d'ordre au départ
mais un nom pour moi le ça me pousse à
aller plus loin ça me pousse à aller
plus loin et d'ailleurs les gens qui
m'ont découragé
m'ont beaucoup plus aidé que ceux qui
m'ont encouragé parce que mon dicton
c'était un prouve d'un rond je vais leur
prouver qu'ils ont tort et ça a été un
moteur qui m'a suivi toute ma vie parce
que dès qu'on ne croyait pas dans mon
dans mon projet ça me stimulait pour
leur trouver qu'ils avaient tort le
milieu financier
canadien québécois vous a pas aidé tant
que ça au début ça peut être facile pour
vrai non non j'ai eu des banquiers qui
étaient surtout des femmes qui ne
croyaient pas dans mon projet qui j'ai
eu des refus beaucoup plus que des que
des acceptations ou des louanges la part
des banques et je me suis débrouillée
seul sans les banques pendant plusieurs
années j'avais mon institut
où je donnais des cours de
l'épanouissement de la personnalité qui
me j'avais revenu qui me permettait de
soutenir ce que je faisais au début j'ai
pas fait bancaire du tout au début et
pourquoi ça a marché croyez-vous vos
produits pourquoi il y a une demande moi
je pense que la qualité mais je pense
aussi que j'avais développé avec mes
émissions télévisions j'avais développé
un climat de confiance parce que j'étais
toujours j'allais toujours au bout de
chaque chose j'avais jamais une réponse
qui était au hasard j'allais chercher
mes réponses auprès des spécialistes les
gens m'écrivaient beaucoup j'avais
beaucoup beaucoup de courrier et je
pense que c'est ce climat de confiance
qui a fait que quand j'ai lancé mes
produits les femmes me connaissaient par
via la télé mais connaissait aussi je
pense ma sincérité en 2010 Lise Watier
crée une fondation pour encourager
l'entrepreneuriat chez les femmes son
programme s'entreprendre oeuvre pour
leur permettre d'atteindre une autonomie
financière
ensuite avec votre succès puis votre
fondation dans plusieurs gestes vous
avez tenté d'aider les femmes aussi
toujours apprendre la parole ça c'est
important pour vous oui parce que
dans les premiers cours dans les
premiers cours que je donnais j'étais
jeune j'avais
on recule beaucoup mais je les incestais
à être elle apprendre parole je pense
qu'il faut prendre sa place
pas besoin d'être arrogante pour prendre
sa place on peut prendre sa place avec
douceur mais si on prend pas notre place
il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui va la
prendre il y a pas encore assez de
femmes d'affaires les oies quand on
regarde la liste je pense qu'il y a une
revue britannique qui disait il y a plus
de Jack de prénom Jack de femmes dans la
liste des 1000 entreprises je pense
qu'il y a peut-être que c'est notre
éducation aussi judéo-chrétienne voyons
une compagnie où il y a un poste vacant
les critères pour obtenir le poste sont
les suivants
un gars de regarder les critères il y en
a pour 60% il va postuler
une femme alors pour 85% de critères
elle va pas postuler pourquoi
c'est ce doute il faut postuler à 85 il
faut postuler à 85 %, il faut postuler à
60% que vous allez apprendre
postuler pour on va apprendre c'est un
chat
depuis ses débuts à la télévision dans
ces négociations pour son entreprise
lise Wattier pendant toutes ces années
en a connu des hommes arrogants elle
salue d'ailleurs le mouvement Mitou un
vent de fraîcheur qui lui a rappelé une
agression dont elle a été victime il y a
60 ans c'est d'ailleurs la première fois
qu'elle en parle publiquement comment
vous avez vécu le mouvement me too et où
on parle de prise de parole ça a été une
prise de parole planétaire comment vous
avez vu ça ce mouvement là des femmes
qui disait c'est assez je suis pour le
mouvement Mitou c'est sûr
ça m'a fait revenir aussi dans mon passé
et je me suis dit à l'époque j'aurais
jamais pensé
accuser quelqu'un
j'aurais jamais jamais pensé je me
rappelle d'un jeune comédien à l'époque
moi j'étais mannequin et je faisais
l'émission du dimanche soir avec Michel
et ce jeune comédien me dit oh
on se liait d'amitié sur le plateau
on a une répétition pour chaque pièce de
théâtre je sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait à telle place à ce que ça
tenterait de venir je dis oui une
répétition c'est avec des comédiens
j'avais 20 ans
et j'arrive dans un endroit quand même
une maison privée dans
l'appartement
il y a un souffle au lit alors je me dis
bah ils vont répéter debout
et là il se met nu devant moi
et Jésus mais qu'est-ce qui te prend et
voyons voyons quoi alors là j'essayais
de sortir puis il y avait c'est une
mauvaise pas la porte je vais crier au
meurtre mais tu vois ça c'était une
intimidation
c'est une agression oui il m'a pas
touché non
je me dis j'aurais jamais eu l'idée de
le dire ou de me plaindre à quelqu'un
est-il encore vivant
et puis je l'ai vu à la télé il y a pas
longtemps dans un rôle mais là il est
vieux
parce qu'il y avait sûrement mon ange
mais au moins ce mouvement là éveillé
toutes celles qui ont d'une façon de
près ou de loin vécu quelque chose de et
ça tu vois ça m'est revenu parce que je
l'avais oublié presque et ça m'est
revenue avec le mouvement je l'avais mis
dans ma mémoire lointaine mais et je
l'ai vu à la télé le jour je dis ce
petit bonjour là
qu'est-ce qui a fait d'autre après
donc c'est sain les outils dans votre
esprit là c'est sain que les femmes et
maintenant cet espace est pris cet
espace en disant savez-vous ça s'est
terminé c'est fini les mots donc c'est
terminé on veut pas les patrons
parce que ça cache toujours quelque
chose d'autre et
je pense que aujourd'hui il y a une
force féminine il y a une force féminine
je pense que les femmes se rendent
compte de la capacité qu'elles ont alors
qu'avant elles ne s'en rendait pas
compte moi je dis j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours aimé dire la force de la
douceur parce que la douceur parfois ça
a beaucoup plus de force que de la
violence
il voit-il donc vous regrettez pas de
pas être devenu médecin ou à votre cadre
ou notaire parce que au départ
vos parents ou vous vous auriez pu vous
ne regrettez pas la voix que vous avez
choisie aucun regret j'ai une belle vie
quand je partirai je dis à tous ceux qui
sont autour de moi dites-vous elle a eu
une vie qu'elle a aimé
j'ai été aimé j'ai été
j'ai des amis extraordinaires j'ai
beaucoup d'amour autour de moi j'ai des
enfants merveilleux j'ai une vie que
j'ai aimé il y a eu des moments
difficiles il y a eu des moments
en questionne mais j'ai une belle vie
et je veux je veux aider encore les
femmes et puis avec la Fondation c'est
très valorisant de voir que 600 femmes
aujourd'hui avec la fondation qui sont
devenus financièrement indépendantes
pour moi c'est un
quand on dit on peut changer la vie de
quelqu'un c'est très très valorisant
est-ce que c'est plus difficile vieillir
pour une femme que pour un homme encore
en 2023
pensez une femme qui a des cheveux
blancs elle est vieille un homme que des
cheveux blancs
c'est un homme qui a bien réussi une
femme qui est bonne elle est grosse
ça change pas ça change pas ça et puis
vieillir je pense que c'est dans la tête
on vieillit si on veut se laisser aller
et si on veut au contraire être actif et
faire n'importe quoi mais du bénévolat
faire du jardinage tricoté faire quelque
chose où on se sent utile parce que si
on se sent inutile on vieillit alors
quelqu'un qui se sent inutile qui est
devant son poste de télé
et qui pensent ces journées
je pense que de se sentir utile de
sentir qu'on aide quelqu'un de sentir
qu'on participe à la vie
ça ça garde en santé ça garde en vie
mais quand je dis ça garde en santé non
ça garde en vie ça nous donne de
l'énergie
quand on se laisse aller on ne cède pas
Elise Voitier merci beaucoup de nous
avoir reçus chez vous vous êtes en
pleine forme vous avez des yeux qui
brillent vos yeux bleus qui brillent
merci beaucoup de nous avoir reçu ça a
été un plaisir Patrice merci